this video is sponsored by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with Squarespace I
think it'd be fair to say that I am
known on YouTube as the guy who makes
videos about how he got his PhD and I
feel like my videos may have
disproportionately encouraged and
motivated people to want to do phd's I'm
not sure how I feel about that
so as an addendum to my PhD vlog series
I wanted to make this honest video
outlining precisely why you prospective
student at home should not apply for a
PhD firstly money if you look at the
average career earnings for graduates
who have PhDs and compare them to
graduates who just have undergraduate
degrees those with PhDs earn 26% more in
total across their careers which sounds
pretty good right you know it's more
money but if you compare the average
career earnings for graduates who have
master's degrees with those who just
have undergraduate degrees those with
master's own 23% more on average than
someone with just an undergraduate
degree so PhD graduates do earn more
than those with master's degrees and
with undergraduate degrees but not much
more than people who just did a masters
and they spent three or four more years
in education further to this PhD
graduates who leave academia and move
into industry face an awful lot of
misconceptions about what having a PhD
means they get pigeonholed they get
accused of being over specialized get
questions like if you have a PhD why
aren't you applying to be a professor if
you have a PhD you ask me some kind of
urban nerd I'm not going to employ you
you must not be able to talk to people
and then during a PhD you earn extremely
little certainly compared to people that
you graduated on your same uni course
with and you weren't extremely little
for an awful lot of work in my final
year of my PhD I was doing 12-hour days
all the time during the last few months
I wouldn't take a day off for months at
a time how about social factors during a
PhD you often work completely alone
you can spend day after
a day just working on your own never
talk to anyone just writing and writing
and writing on a laptop and if you're
unfortunate enough to have an
inattentive supervisor you can be left
completely adrift by them and not have
any clue what you're supposed to be
doing you have a much higher probability
of developing mental health problems
during a PhD good luck trying to
maintain a healthy social life a healthy
relationship a healthy work-life balance
a healthy sleeping schedule health
during my PhD I developed psychosomatic
breathing problems meaning my mental
health had deteriorated to the point
where I couldn't physically breathe and
those PhD students that do make it
through all of that and stay in academia
then face years and years of low pay
long hours and changing city every
couple of years to chase new jobs the
early stages of an academic career are a
constant grind of teaching and research
and relocation what I'm saying is you
shouldn't apply for a PhD if you value
money or prestige or power or a
comfortable life why on earth would
anyone willingly sign up to do a PhD
because they're passionate about
something there are plenty of negatives
about doing a PhD and there are lots of
reasons why you shouldn't do one but
really this video should be called why
you should do the PhD but that will get
way fewer views despite having identical
information in it so got a play on those
psychological factors to answer the
question of why you should do a PhD you
have to ask what is a PhD a PhD is an
opportunity to push the envelope of
human knowledge a tiny bit and learn
stuff that nobody else has ever learned
before it's an opportunity funded to a
certain minimum amount enough money to
make sure that you can live and you can
learn these new things but no more than
that and then in exchange for that
funding the only thing you need to do is
when you do learn something new and you
do push the boundaries of human
knowledge you publish it in such a way
that other people can benefit from what
you've learned too in this sense a PhD
is like a contract Society invests in
you and you then provide a return on
that investment in the form of a better
understanding of something so you should
apply for a PhD if you're passionate
about something and you think that
spending three or four years of your
life at this stage in your life doing
nothing but that thing is the best use
of your time on earth it's that simple
don't apply for a PhD if you want to
earn lots of money because you're not
gonna earn much more money than if you
just did a masters don't apply for a PhD
if you want some swanky job that's what
you're shooting for because yes I should
mention that some jobs do ask for a PhD
that's a fair point but for an awful lot
of jobs it sometimes seems that having a
PhD is a disadvantage apply to do a PhD
if you are passionate about something
academic because you need that passion
otherwise you won't survive you have to
be able to happily see yourself doing
the thing you're passionate about every
day for three or four years and then
even those people that go into a PhD
with that conviction still hate their
PhD by the end of it and a lot of those
people who go in with that conviction
still drop out halfway through the PhD
because the difficulties like I
mentioned earlier are immense every
single person I've spoken to at the end
of their PhD was desperate for it to be
done they were just done with the whole
thing and that even includes professors
when I asked them about their PhDs they
were desperate to be finished by the end
of it I interviewed a bunch of PhD
supervisors at my uni a couple of years
ago and asked them what they looked for
in a PhD students here are a few of
their answers a PhD student has to have
the technical background to in the area
of study which which is a given if
they're up if they're applying but what
I like to see is PhD students who are
enthusiastic about the topic that that
they're gonna be studying and are ready
to get going on it and genuinely want to
push the frontiers of knowledge and they
want to go out and share it okay if you
if you're thinking of applying for a PhD
ask yourself a question why you would
like to do that and if the answer is
because you're really interested in the
topic and you're really interested in
doing research on that topic then do a
PhD don't do it because you think it's a
good you know these days I look for
people that are quite focused but also
have a going to drive to understand
things they kind of get research it
excites them no everyone does mean some
people do research because they think
this is sort of what we do I'm a club I
did a good degree we come to do a PhD
and they just think they never really
get it and there was no light goes on a
no point do they either think this is
really frustrating which is okay it
should be frustrating or this is really
exciting they just think boring this and
they're not cared for research that
bright people don't kind of reserved so
ask yourself if you've been inspired by
my videos or if you're thinking about
doing a PhD seriously ask yourself why
do you want to do this what do you value
do you think that spending the next
three or four years of your life
following what you're passionate about
doing what you really enjoy doing it's
the best use of your time at this point
in your life or do you value money more
or power or prestige or a comfortable
life more if you do that's absolutely
fine but you shouldn't apply for a PhD
whoa everything got a little bit real
there I felt like I had to make this
video in order to think of myself as a
responsible educational youtuber I think
it's great that people watch my videos
and they want to do a PhD but I think
it's super important that people
understand what they're letting
themselves in for which i think they
probably do get from the vlogs but also
what having a PhD does for you what it
means because I've definitely been
seeing a lot of comments recently from
people that really misunderstand what a
PhD is before so everything got very
real here much much more so than on my
channel normally but I think this is
important and I hope that it that it's
useful to some people if you've watched
a whole bunch of educational content on
YouTube which
if you're watching my channel you almost
certainly have then you know what comes
next next we have me recommending use
some products or service giving you a
link of some kind and then moving on to
a final video summary or evaluation in
this case though this is super easy for
me because I've been sponsored by a
company that I've been personally using
for ages and they're Squarespace I've
been using Squarespace to host my
website simonez comm for months and it's
a hub for everything I do so it you know
my podcast my videos and in the future
I'm going to be putting my PhD thesis on
there once I've finished my Corrections
and when I do put my thesis online I
know it's going to be incredibly easy
it's probably gonna take me all of 30
seconds to upload my thesis and put it
on my website as a matter of fact when I
set up my website early this month to
start handling merchandise I genuinely
couldn't believe how easy it was I
personally recommend it to anyone who
wants to sell merchandise online or just
have your own website it's it's honestly
that good if you have a project that
you're passionate about and you want to
build a website for it that's gonna look
great and be super easy to run then go
to Squarespace comm for a free trial and
then when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace comm forward slash Simon
Clark to get 10% off your first website
or domain Thank You Squarespace for
sponsoring me it's super easy to
recommend your product because I use it
and I think it's great and thank you for
watching this video I would say that I
hope it doesn't put you off applying for
a PhD but I kind of do for some people I
think it's important that you understand
what having a PhD means for you and what
you're letting yourself in for by
applying for one actually on that
subject if you haven't seen them already
definitely check out my PhD blocks up
here somewhere and thank you again for
watching the video if you enjoyed it too
please give it a like and if you're not
subscribed to the channel consider
subscribing I'll see you in the next one
[Music]